sounds like that you take it slow with
people especially people that are
celebrities and and maybe they're used
to people with different agendas coming
at them yeah what are bad the best one I
have
this is the most full circle you'll ever
hear story ever right now you're gonna
you and your husband talk later like
that's the best story anyone's ever told
on film curse is I grew up
oh sure yeah so I grew up uh loving the
show Beverly Hills 90210 as a kid uh
there was a girl I liked in high school
and uh shocker she it wasn't
reciprocated but she invited me over to
come watch the show when I was like a
junior in high school and I'd never seen
it and there's this character Dylan
McKay he's like the coolest dude and uh
you know all the all the guys wanted to
to be him and all the girls wanted to be
with them so I after that I was just
like kind of been admirer of the actor
Luke Perry so
fast forward a number of years I'm back
I'm at NASCAR I know I'm going to leave
and we're doing this project This World
War II thing about a racer a race car
owner who served in World War II and won
the Purple Heart so I was like I think
I'll get Luke Perry to narrate this
because I had nothing to lose at this
point
and uh he narrates it and I remember one
of the executives saying like why why is
Luke Perry narrating this I'm like oh
his father served in World War II
complete [__] so
um he narrates it went well don't really
think much more it was really cool to
work with him so then about a year later
I'm doing a project for ESPN and they're
looking for a narrator that kind of had
like for Nostalgia purposes was big in
the 90s so I'd bring up Luke Perry I'm
like I just worked with this guy earlier
this year I sent them the show they're
like oh he's got a great voice so now
I'm back in front of him working working
with Luke again and he's like hey I have
an idea I'd like to do a documentary I'm
like let's do it gives me his number now
I'm like oh this is awesome now like
working with Luke we wind up doing a
documentary together about
um Marge shot the This Racist baseball
owner that was on ESPN and we just kind
of form a friendship you just meet some
people sometimes you just connect
instantaneously he and I just hit it off
hung out every time I was in LA if he
was in town we'd hang out and just a
great dude
um
he had me over for Christmas when I was
going through a divorce he invited me
over to spend Christmas because I didn't
have my kids with me and I go over to
his house I'm thinking like it's going
to be like a Walsh family Christmas I'm
going to come in nobody's there it's
just him and his fiance he's like
offering me like day old chili and I go
Luke what's going on and he's going to
Bora Bora the next day on vacation and I
go where is everybody he goes oh no it's
just us and I said why why did you
invite me over if we're just
hanging out and he said well
uh I I remember my first Christmas
without my kids and I didn't want you to
be alone
so just a real like Heart of Gold person
so he started developing uh the movie
Grace Point with me
um before he passed away
and he was going to play one of the
roles in it
so sadly he he passed away but before he
did he was like you know he's like I
really like you to meet my friend this
girl that I know she grew up in my
hometown our families or friends she
just moved to Charlotte
and I was like all right I was like I
kind of have a girlfriend but he's like
yeah give me your number and then he's
like okay I'll have her call you and she
never called you know and I'd bring it
up to him and be like I don't know what
her deal is she still didn't call you
and I'm like nope and I'm like he's like
I guess she's just not interested I said
I guess so then he passes away
and I get a message on Instagram from
from this woman Michelle saying hey Luke
talked about you a lot
he really wanted us to meet and I don't
really have anyone to grieve him with in
Charlotte would you want to get lunch so
we went we got lunch
and then we wound up going to his
funeral Memorial together in LA and uh
we've been together ever since we got
married last year so that Luke kind of
brought us together and then my movie
Grace Point is dedicated to Luke at the
end it's the last thing on screen so it
was pretty he's somebody who had a huge
impact on my life probably as much as
anyone in my entire life he's had an
impact and that's crazy too because you
said that you went to the girl's house
that you liked to watch 90210
and it like it's like it kind of came
full circle yeah because it didn't work
out with her but then that's fascinating
yeah it didn't work out when I was 15
but yeah no uh he he and he you know I
think in life and this this is important
for viewers you should try to gravitate
towards people who celebrate you not
just tolerate you and I think in this
industry sometimes people just are kind
of putting up with you it seems like
sometimes and but you will meet people
that believe in you there's only a few
that you'll meet and it doesn't matter
what Walk of Life they're in but keep
them with keep them close to you when
Luke was making Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood we went out like literally he
was filming that day and we met for
dinner and he was telling me about
Quentin Tarantino
and I said what's it like working with
and he said I said what's his best
quality and he I thought Luke was gonna
say he's the best writer he's got the
best dialogue and he said he's the
nicest director I've ever worked with
I'm like really and he's like yeah I go
he treats everyone so good on the set
and he would call Luke on his way home
and tell him what a great job he did and
he I could tell he really made Luke
feel great about himself you know and I
was like wow like that is so cool so it
looks more I went up to Quentin
Tarantino and told him that I told him
that like Luke said these and Tarantino
was like thank you thank you for telling
that really means a lot to me and he
really appreciated it but Luke said to
me he's like he's like you remind me of
uh Quentin I'm like shut the hell up and
he's like no he said the way your
enthusiasm and whatever and he said to
me he said I'm gonna be at your movie
premiere someday so he wasn't there but
I felt like he was there in spirit
so that was it was
um and his name was on the screen
um so he he was somebody that always
made me feel like I could make the
transition from documentary to scripted
like he was never telling me all the
reasons why I couldn't do it he was just
telling me all the reasons why I could
so you know try to find those people in
your life if you can
um that motivate you I believe in you
and if you find that people aren't uh
tolerating you but you need to have them
there for whatever reason yeah then do
it with Grace how
how do you approach that well as much as
you can try to surround yourself with
the the celebrate as much as you have
that control look when you're starting
out it's not going to be that way
obviously but as you when you can pick
situations more I mean look
there's
for whatever reason some people just
aren't you're not going to be their cup
of tea for whatever reason and you can
waste a lot of energy and a lot of time
trying to win them over when sometimes
you can say look it's just not meant to
be and I'm gonna be with these people
that kind of seem to get me and and want
to be around me and all that so
just you know as you embark on these
situations and when you're trying to get
especially in an independent film made
you know you I've heard stories on your
site about DPS and and directors not
getting along I mean what more important
relationship is there than a DP and a
director they should be like the best of
friends like you should be hanging my DP
and my director I mean we're like
simpatico I mean we're like this he's
like my number one partner so it's like
why would you be with a DP that you
don't they that's fighting you the whole
time like there's plenty of people out
there you can work with you don't unless
he's like give me the camera for free or
something or his dad's funding it
get a different TP that would be my
Don't force yourself in these terrible
situations if you can